alors les screens on vient chercher sa
petite histoire on vient chercher son
petit père castor son petit moment de
réconfort vous êtes open en droit vous
le savez je suis passionné par des
histoires de gens culotté des mecs qui
sont bat les couilles on avait donc vu
ensemble l'histoire de john mcafee qui
d'ailleurs est mort quelques semaines
après ma vidéo jésuite pour les ranger
tout de suite vos pistolets les cov on
avait aussi vu l'histoire de seeland où
un mec avait décidé qu'une plateforme
lui appartenait et allait même être
maintenant un pays vous avez
probablement tous vu passer des vidéos
ou des documentaires sur des
narcotrafiquants le plus connu d'entre
tous étant pablo escobar et bien sachez
que si pablo escobar et son cartel au
cartel de medellin sont devenus aussi
puissant c'est grâce à un mec qui lui
est beaucoup moins connue carlos l'es2
le plus fou c'est qu'il est aujourd'hui
encore vivant et en liberté alors que
c'est grâce à lui si au début des années
80 la drogue aux états unis c'est parti
en couille jdo l'a pas eu tous ces gens
jugent je suis fasciné par des humains
qui en ont rien à [ __ ] des règles et
qui ont un culot pas possible simplement
j'aime bien savoir ce qui les a amenés à
devenir comme ça à faire ces choses-là
et carlos lehder n'échappe pas à la
règle avant de vous raconter son
histoire place un petit h taghane le
petit truc magique est tous là c'est
pour faire passer le ht
lalalala j'adore les fêtes foraines
[Musique]
raconte pas ta vie je suis un zombie
trop stylé c'est comme sedan state of
survival eux je sais pas peut-être mais
si ce jeu de survie là
je me tape tu as tort car en ce moment
il fait leurs deux ans donc ils font un
gros événement avec plein de cadeaux et
des héros légendaires qui sont
totalement gratuits pour une durée
limitée comme moi par exemple je sais
pas qui tu es t'as jamais vu un walking
dead ça craint tu as oublié de préciser
qu'en plus il y un giveaway du kit de
survie ultime jusqu'à la fin de
l'événement qui inclut une véritable
lamborghini or à cannes mais toi aussi
tu fais le placement de produits non moi
je bosse ici et c'est parti reproche
bien vos ceintures ok bref pour
participer au jeu il faut inscrire
inviter d'autres personnes à télécharger
le jeu pour compléter quelques missions
facile et après tenter le concours et
c'est gratuit pour participer ça a duré
longtemps du 1er septembre au 31 octobre
je parlais de ton exposé annonce assez
bon j'ai fini super g tout bouffer mais
tu trouveras mon lien en description on
oublie pas qu il y a une véritable
voiture à la clé abbas sympa tu veux
faire un tour de manège vas-y qu'elle
est l'enfance de carlos leader alors on
pourrait penser qu'il a eu une enfance
assez dingue pour devenir l'un des plus
gros narcotrafiquants des années 80 pas
du tout il a eu une enfance totalement
cool faut savoir que son père est un
ingénieur allemand qui réussit plutôt
bien dans les affaires à tel point qu du
coup il devient expatriés en colombie et
là bas ils bossent pour des immeubles
très huppé du pays dans lequel il fait
installer s'il vous plaît les tout
premiers ascenseur beau gosse et donc la
famille laideur gagne énormément
d'argent à tel point qu'en plus de leurs
activités ascenseur est ce qu'ils vont
ouvrir une taverne des entreprises dans
la production d'huile végétale et des
entreprises dans l'importation de
produits de luxe bref jusque là sa
famille c'est une petite succès story on
est loin du cliché de l'enfant des rues
qui a grandi au milieu de la délinquance
pas du tout il ya quand même un petit
problème c'est que le père de carlos
leader est un énorme nazis voilà il
grandit donc dans une ambiance un peu
chelou au sein d'une famille plutôt
aisée mais qui a quand même un passif ac
v ner qu'est ce qui se passe quand
carlos à 15 ans parce que plein d'autres
n'ont vécu ses parents divorcent et
c'est sa mère qui obtient sa garde
étonnant n'est ce pas comment ça on ne
confie pas entre les mains d'un asie à
partir de là sa mère veut le mieux pour
lui et elle veut pas qu'il ait de
mauvaises fréquentations en colombie du
coup elle va emménager avec lui à new
york sur place car le sel vocation c'est
d'être médecin pour ça il va mener à
bien ces études il est plutôt brillant à
l'école et va même pendant son cursus
sauver des vies tout est faux tout en
arrivant à new york qui cherchent un peu
quoi faire et il se met d'accord sur une
stratégie qui consiste à voler des
caisses volet des caisses pour les
revendre au canada et au cas où ça fait
pas assez d'argent à côté on va deal est
un peu de drogue le rêve américain
lassés il est mort alors évidemment ses
ambitions et ce plan de carrière très
solide l'emmène tout droit à un endroit
et vie dans la prison dans laquelle il
va faire une rencontre décisive pour le
reste de sa vie malheureusement celle de
zhang zhong george jones est un
trafiquant de cannabis mais un
trafiquant qui a de l'expérience il
connaît très bien les rouages de ce game
à tel point que george hill a créé une
manière de faire passer de la drogue à
travers la frontière américaine il
suffit de faire voler des avions de
tourisme depuis le mexique sous les
radars américains et de les poser à la
rage dans des petits aérodromes
apparemment ça passe passe qui aurait
tellement de trafic aérien qu'il est
impossible pour les autorités de
vérifier tous les appareils qui
atterrissent dans tous les aérodromes à
l'époque le seul moyen de faire passer
de la drogue à une frontière c'est
d'avoir une mule c'est à dire de
planquer des toutes petites quantités de
drogue sur des gens qui voyagent
normalement la technique de georges la
cdu au niveau clairement tu fais passer
largement plus de drogues carlos i va
donc s'instruire tous les jours ils
écoutent georges et tous les jours il
prend des notes quelles sont les routes
à utiliser les techniques pour éviter
les douanes comment on fait pour
blanchir l'argent cette fois il est sûr
de sa vocation professionnelle il veut
en sortant de prison est un énorme
trafiquants de cocaïne aux états unis on
né en 1976 carlos et georges sortent de
prison leur priorité faire de la thune
mon pote pour ça il commença il recrute
des jeunes américaines hiller peu les
vacances tous frais payés aux caraïbes
ils les font revenir aux us avec une
valise remplie de cocaïne ils vont faire
ça pas mal de fois jusqu'à obtenir leur
premier million de dollars à partir de
là ils peuvent maintenant acheter un
avion privé et obtenir les services d'un
pilote certifié plus besoin de faire au
cas par cas et de ramener un peu de
drogue dans une valise là ils ont un
avion avec une suti la remplissent de
drogue à chaque fois d'accord ils ont un
plan très simple devenir pote avec des
colombiens pour recevoir des cargaisons
de drogue l'avion part du mexique il
arrive aux bahamas et ensuite ils font
la fameuse technique de georges pour
pouvoir déposer la drogue aux états unis
à savoir i vol sous les radars ça peut
pas être aussi simple ça va foirer ça
marche à la perfection ils ont plus en
plus de contacts en colombie ils font
passer de plus en plus de drogues aux
états unis il gagne de plus en plus
d'argent à tel point qu'en colombie on
commence pas mal à parler d'eux et qu'on
avait surnommé les cocaïne cowboys ils
vont faire ça pendant deux ans mais
carlos vous le connaissez et là les yeux
plus gros que le ventre et en découdre
et il a une nouvelle idée il à une
réunion avec georges son associé et lui
dit pourquoi on n'achète pas
au bahamas parce que là le nombre
d'avions et de drogue qu'on va pouvoir
faire passer ça va être une dinguerie
douche froide georges il trouve ça
beaucoup trop risqué et les deux hommes
vont carrément ne plus être associés se
séparent carlos en revient pas il est
découragé il vient de perdre son associé
les sdi mais je m'en bats les couilles
je vais l'acheter mon il est bienvenu à
norman skies messieurs dames vous
profiterez bien sûr de sa base nautique
de son club de yacht et de la bonne
humeur des quelques résidents qui vit
tout ce qui lui reste à faire c'est donc
de convaincre les retraités résidant de
lui vendre leur maison et pour sa carlos
il a pensé à tout il implore redoutable
il va se faire passer pour un agent
immobilier sous le nom de joe leader il
a même pas changé son nom cet [ __ ] en
revanche vous connaissez les retraités
ils sont trop bien dans leur maison sur
leur île ils veulent pas peu importe le
prix face à ce problème carlos grand
diplomate décide tout simplement de
faire venir 20 gardes armés d'une milice
privée allemande il se barre tous sauf
l'un d'entre eux laissez moi vous
présenter ce cher monsieur richard novak
c'est un américain passionné de biologie
sous-marine et son kiff son petit passe
temps c'est d'aller nager avec les
requins et autour de l'île se trouve
énormément de requins dont pour lui
c'est vraiment le paradis c'est sa
passion mais carlos mena son petit coin
de paradis du coup novak ne cède pas il
reste sur l'île et il va tenir tête aux
cartels et on se parle de tenir tête
jean frontale par exemple il va saboter
les réservoirs d'essence des avions de
carlos qui transportent de la drogue en
les remplissant deux sacs à nager avec
des requins ça donne des couilles énorme
il aurait aussi eu quelques fusillades
tout simplement avec la milice de carlos
dans lesquelles il aurait frôlé la mort
au moins de quatre fois
mais ça sent mito l'unique source de ses
informations c'est richard lui même il
ya plus ou moins que lui qui est capable
de confirmer ce qui est vrai ou faux là
dedans malgré tout le nom de richard
novak apparaît quand même dans des
rapports officiels des autorités
américaines et honnêtement ce qu'ils
disent à son sujet ça reste héroïque en
gros nova qu'il aurait bel et bien
refusé de quitter l'île par contre il
serait pas parti dans les trucs de
gunfight et tout ça il a juste fumer du
crack et l'oréal inverse fait profil bas
mais il aurait espionné le cartel il
aurait donné aux autorités d
immatriculation des avions qui se
posaient sur l'île il aurait expliqué un
peu c'est quoi les techniques de carlos
fin vraiment le gard d'informateurs
parfait quoi ces infos été mise entre
les mains de la 10è pour ce qu'ont vu
breaking bad marcos etc vous savez très
bien ce que c'est là dit elle pour les
autres basse et l'administration
américaine qui lutte contre la drogue et
contre les mets qui achètent des îles
pour faire passer encore plus de drogue
peu de temps après avoir donné toutes
ces infos à la 10è novak il a du flair
il n'est pas con il se dit bon ben là je
vais me balance énormément
d'informations sur des gens qui veulent
ma mort peut-être je prends fils je mets
dans ma valise et je me casse ils seront
donc à l'aérodrome pour prendre son
avion et faire un aller simple aux états
unis sauf qu'en arrivant sur place qui
l'attend ces cas car c'est l'os c'est
carlos est là carlos va faire une petite
dame gris ici faute de l'essence du
moteur de l'avion de novak et ils le
forcent lui et son fils a décollé en
pleine nuit direction les états unis
avec seulement quelques litres d'essence
dans son réservoir autant vous dire
qu'il peut voler trois minutes novak a
pas trop le choix il déconne avec son
fils est évidemment son avion va
s'écraser faute de carburant mais les
deux s'en sortent indemnes des histoires
sombres comme ça il y en ad'autres
carlos il a des pratiques
narcotrafiquants pesc durée par exemple
quelques avions de tourisme qui se
serait écrasé sur l'île et carlos aurait
donné l'ordre de laisser mourir les
occupants des avions pour pas que une
fois de retour aux etats unis puissent
raconter ce qu'ils ont vu sur l'île et
se seraient pas des légendes puisque
apparemment encore aujourd'hui on trouve
pas mal de carcasse d'avion sur l'île ce
qui accrédite ces rumeurs bref vous
l'aurez compris carlos il veut rester
pour le moment discret carlos passe la
seconde elle a en gros son île ça
devient une sorte d'entrepôt amazon
gigantesque mais pour la drogue il fait
construire des hangars pour les avions
il fait construire une tour de contrôle
des radars descente réfrigéré pour
stocker la cocaïne et pour faire tourner
tout ça il emploi à plein temps une
quarantaine de personnes faut comprendre
que là ce qui vient de mettre au point
ces extrêmement puissant en seulement
quelques minutes une dizaine d'avions
tourisme peuvent être remplis de cocaïne
décollé direction les états unis toutes
les villes côtières sont inondés par la
cocaïne et norman's cay devient du jour
au lendemain une plaque tournante du
narcotrafic américain dites vous que le
mec a tellement innover dans le milieu
de la drogue que plus tard un procureur
américain d'irak carlos était au marché
de la drogue ce qui était henry ford au
monde de l'automobile il a vraiment
révolutionné le game bref tous les
cartels entendre parler d'un mec
incroyable qui serait capable de faire
passer énormément de drogue aux états
unis sans se faire cramer y compris le
cartel de medellin et pablo escobar les
deux hommes se rencontrent et ils
s'associent après ce deal on estime que
chaque jour carlos faisait passer 300 kg
de cocaïne sur le sol américain c'est
colossal c'est du jamais vu et carlos
devient milliardaire dit vous qui veut
entrer tellement d'argent qu'il à
l'insolence de proposer à son pays la
colombie de rembourser 8 même sa dette
nationale c'est vous dire la richesse et
le culot du macm ont évidemment la
colombie a dit casse toi alors on veut
dire que vu son importance dans le
trafic de drogue carlos est un mec droit
qui touche pas aux produits qui fait les
rendez-vous qui est diplomate un peu à
l'image d'un gouffre in dans breaking
bad par exemple eh bien devinez quoi il
ya des gens qui arrivent en avant on
donc plein de prostituées qui font la
fête tenue pendant des jours sur sa
plage privée avant de commenter tout le
reste de la semaine bref sur son île
c'est la débauche la plus totale à ce
stade on se pose une question qui est la
question qu'on se pose à chaque fois
dans ces vidéos histoire comment ils
restent impunis dans son cas la réponse
est simple cash is king il les pétés de
thunes et il arrose tout le monde en
pots de vin il peut corrompent
littéralement qui il veut aux bahamas et
c'est d'ailleurs une fois qu'il a
compris ça qu'il a commencé à être un
peu moins discret il a par exemple donné
des interviews à des journalistes
américains en disant qu'il déteste les
états unis le gouvernement américain
voit toutes ses interviews voit tout ce
que ce mec peut dire et ça les fait
chier et commence à faire de plus en
plus de reda norman's cay sauf qu'à
chaque fois qu'ils arrivent aucun avion
aucune drogue rien d'illégal sur l'île
pourquoi parce que carlos a plein d'
espions partout et parmi ces espions se
trouve le premier ministre banner
premier ministre qui est payé 400 mille
dollars à chaque fois qu'il prévient
carlos d'un raid américain carlo se sent
donc intouchable ce qui fait qu'il va
encore plus ouvrir sa gueule qu'avant et
qui va même faire des trucs de
provocation envers les états unis par
exemple lors de la fête d'indépendance
des bahamas ils inondent le ciel de
tracts sur lesquels il a marqué 10 à
gorom en plus d'y attacher un billet de
100 dollars il fait le malin carlos mais
t'inquiète pas aux bahamas personnes au
agir contre les officiels corrompus et
carlos ya quand même une fois un
politicien qu'a osé ouvrir sa gueule
contre carlos et le lendemain sa maison
a mystérieusement explosé mais ça après
ça peut être humble m de tuyaux mais les
amis bonne nouvelle on est en 81 ans et
c'est finalement le début des ennuis
pour carlos jusque là carlos en sortait
grâce à ces complicités aux bahamas mais
pas que c'est aussi grâce au refus de la
colombie d'extrader ses ressortissants
c'est un truc qui a sauvé beaucoup de
narcotrafiquants pendant une période en
tout cas puisque en gros ça bloque les
us sur leurs agissements face à des mecs
qui nuisent à leur territoire en
important des tonnes de cocaïne les
états unis commencent à mettre de plus
en plus la pression à la colombie et
donc les narcotrafiquants et compris
carlos doivent réagir alors que fait
carlos bas il fait son petit parti
politique tout simplement messieurs
dames voici le mobile viento latino
nationale leur revendication principale
construire des pistes cyclables pas du
tout il ya un seul objectif pas
d'extradition please malgré le programme
un peu creux ils vont quand même obtenir
à certaines élections près de 10% des
voix ce qui est vraiment pas dégueu et
ce qui est probablement lié au fait qu à
tous leurs meetings ils arrosent les
gens d'argent la suite de l'histoire
pour ceux qui connaissent l'histoire
table escobar vous la connaissez il ya
plus en plus d'hommes politiques et
autres en colombie qui ose avouer qu'ils
sont pour l'extradition et pour lutter
contre ça carlos et les autres bas tu tu
es journaliste et tu fais un papier en
faveur de l'extradition bon tu es mort
tué un juge qui bossent sur ça bon tu es
mort tué le ministre de la justice et tu
veux faire passer cette loi en temps tu
es mort et oui ils ont vraiment tué le
ministre de la justice et c'est à cause
de ça que la colombie va enfin finir par
autoriser d'extradition l'immunité de
carlos en prend un coup et elle reprend
un coup deux ans plus tard en 83 en gros
un journaliste américain nbc révèle au
grand jour l'ampleur de la corruption
aux bahamas les bahaméen peuvent plus
faire semblant de rien voir ils doivent
se désolidariser de carlos et ils
doivent coopérer avec les états unis
carlos est blacklisté il a plus droit
d'aller à norman siegel ses comptes
bancaires sont gelés bref en 24 heures
il passe de milliardaires a fauché la
police investit lille mais comme
d'habitude carlos s'enfuit avant leur
arrivée et retourne dans son pays natal
la colombie il va se cacher dans la
jungle pendant quelques temps ils
auraient pu croiser d'ailleurs mcafee ça
aurait fait un feat assez incroyable
mais il a un nouveau plan de carrière il
veut vendre du crack
il n'avons pas trop de ces erreurs
carlos avant de mener à bien ce nouveau
projet dont quand même faire profil bas
et c'est le cartel de pablo escobar qui
va l'aider le cartel de medellin et qui
va se charger de le planquer pendant
quelques années après pablo escobar il a
quand même envie de mettre des grandes
vagues comme ça dans la tête de cardio
il a l'impression qu'il ya un lien entre
ces petites interview à la télé ces
petits trolls là avec les traquent dans
le ciel qui disent gorom dit m et le
fait que son cartel vient de perdre le
point le plus stratégique pour importer
de la drogue aux états unis mais alors
comment cette histoire finie et ça c'est
le plus marrant en 1987 carlos fait
encore une dingue pablo escobar organise
une grande fête tous les gens du cartel
sont conviés et c'est évidemment la
débauche absolue et décide de passer la
nuit avec une meuf qui s'avère être la
meuf d'un autre membre du cartel carton
jaune carlos et il faut savoir que cet
autre mec est aussi présent à la soirée
carton rouge carlos le mec en question
cram carlos qui fait des trucs avec sa
meuf et carlos dans l'embrouillé sort à
un flingue et où le mec voilà du coup
que fait pablo escobar à votre avis les
regards carlos et lui dit carlos mon
frère tu as besoin de repos des fatigues
et regarde ce que tu fais ça va pas on
va te mettre un peu au vert là dans un
ranch isolé à la campagne ça va te faire
du bien
en réalité pas le brusque au bar il y en
a ras le cul de devoir rattraper les
conneries de carlos i prévient donc la
police colombienne de la présence de
carlos dans un ranch au large de la
colombie et le 4 février 87 carlos est
arrêté par les policiers colombiens et
extradé aux états unis il est jugé et
les américains ne rigole pas du tout
avec lui parce que c'est la première
fois qu'ils ont un mec aussi aux
placiers d'un cartel entre les mains
clairement ils veulent lui mettre très
cher carlos est accusé d'avoir fait
rentrer plus 80% de la cocaïne présente
aux états unis entre 1978 et 1981 je
vous ai pas menti quand je vous ai dit
qu'il a révolutionné le truc bon il est
finalement condamné à perpétuité et au
cas où on sait jamais il prend en plus
de cinq cent trente cinq ans ferme on
sait jamais mais souvenez-vous ce que je
vous ai dit au début de la vidéo le plus
fou c'est qu'il est aujourd'hui encore
vivant et en liberté eh ben il a eu une
chance énorme au moment de son
arrestation les us sont littéralement en
guerre contre le dictateur du panama
manuel noriega
et devinez qui connaît tous les petits
secrets de noriega genre ses liens avec
les cartels colombiens ces cas car c'est
l'os c'est carlos et témoigne contre lui
et réussi à faire sauter sa peine de
perpétuité et à réduire ses 130 50
fermes à 55 ans finalement carlos est
sorti de prison l'année dernière en 2020
après au final une trentaine d'années
derrière les barreaux il a été transféré
incognito en allemagne sous un nouveau
nom une sous une fausse identité il
essaierait de mener une vie tranquille
et sans accroc aujourd'hui laissant loin
derrière lui tous ces trucs de cartels
de drogue
bref c'est la fin de l'histoire de
carlos leader que je trouve assez
incroyable et surtout je trouve ça fou
que le mec aujourd'hui soit en totale
liberté alors que c'est lui qui a
littéralement révolutionné le trafic de
drogue aux états unis j'espère que ça
vous a plu là je sens qu'on va tous se
regarder marcos je le sens qui est une
excellente série il faut bien le dire je
me suis régalé à vous raconter ça est à
découvrir tout ça sur ce mec dont
j'ignorais quasiment l'existence
dernière petite info ce mec était un
énorme fan de john lennon qui a
finalement les valeurs inverse des
cartels de l'époque il était tellement
fan de lui qu'il avait fait construire
une statue géante devant son hôtel de
john lennon mais un john lennon un peu
revisitée
j'ai rien à dire c'est ok bref l'excuser
on se retrouve dans une prochaine vidéo
très bientôt c'était peut-être un peu
long je sais pas où tu que j'ai kiffé à
bientôt ciao
[Musique]